y hoy hablaron los líderes de brasil de
colombia de chile de perú del salvador
argentina y también de mexico cuál es su
conclusión sobre sus intervenciones y
qué peso tienen en este el evento
diplomático más grande del mundo en el
segundo año de pandemia
con las buenas noches hay que entender
que el peso del surf global hoy es mucho
más importante que hace unos años en
buena medida porque el papel de américa
latina por ejemplo en atajar el
calentamiento global su contribución en
buena medida por la vulnerabilidad
además que tiene es cada vez más
importante además por la biodiversidad
que concentra en segundo lugar es
importante américa latina porque es una
región clave en la lucha contra el cob y
creo que el norte industrializado sabe
que si el sur global no está inmunizado
no habrá una solución de largo plazo
frente a la pandemia y en tercer lugar
es importante porque se esperaba
muchísimo el discurso del presidente de
brasil muy criticado por por su política
en la amazonía de vacunas el discurso
del presidente colombiano que hace un
crítico del posconflicto entonces
digamos que también ha habido un interés
individual por las expectativas que
generan algunos mandatarios respecto de
la situación interna
bueno hablando de ese tema pues hubo
algunas protestas contra el mandatario
brasileño jair bolsonaro hoy en nueva
york' y la causa fue precisamente la
crisis indígena y las explotaciones de
la selva amazónica sin embargo por otro
lado también el mandatario se mantiene
coherente con su política anti vacunas
se le vio comiéndose una pizza en la
calle porque no puede entrar a los
restaurantes al no estar inmunizado y le
preguntó por estos reproches que le
hacen al mandatario porque imagen
presenta la economía más grande de
américa latina en este evento
una imagen deplorable porque brasil ha
abandonado todos sus compromisos
respecto a la defensa de la
biodiversidad en la amazonía
sobre bolsonaro llueven las acusaciones
por un genocidio y ecocidio en esta
región se le acusaba además por la
irresponsabilidad evidente frente al
hobbit digamos que el gobierno brasileño
ha sido portador de noticias falsas y en
tercer lugar es muy riesgoso lo que está
pasando respecto en la democracia
esta idea de amenazar al congreso
amenazar a los jueces la imagen que
tenemos hoy de brasil es deplorable es
un país alejado de la trayectoria
multilateral que lo marcó durante las
últimas décadas y más preocupante aún
porque fue su discurso al que audio está
esta sesión de la asamblea general de
naciones unidas bueno y sin embargo la
tendencia ha sido una creciente derecha
en américa latina y de eso pues ese
testigo ya ayer bolsonaro esto se vio
reflejado en la jornada de hoy qué
efecto causa este giro en los países
latinos y en los discursos
causan giro sobre todo en américa latina
porque estos gobiernos conservadores
digamos que tienen una distancia frente
a los procesos de regionalización se han
venido enfriando como ocurriendo el caso
de la celac que está inactiva hace ya
cuatro años y está tratando de ser
relanzada por el gobierno izquierda
andrés manuel lópez obrador de igual
forma la oea está paralizada en buena
medida por el control que tienen los
gobiernos conservadores del secretario
general pero esto para ser sinceros no
tiene un impacto muy visible en la
política global y lo que vemos
concretamente es como como ocurre en
europa y en otras regiones del mundo hay
una suerte de nuevo nacionalismo del que
américa latina pues obviamente no puede
y no ha sido ajena